ahora es momento de hablar de economía y
por ello nos acompaña aquí en el estudio
nuestra periodista daniela blandón
daniela bienvenida vamos a iniciar con
el gobierno de cuba que eliminaría los
subsidios a los restaurantes estatales
valentina muy buenas noches pues por lo
menos así lo ha dicho en sus más
recientes discursos el sucesor de raúl
castro- miguel díaz canel en una medida
que hace parte de una esperada reforma
monetaria en el país caribeño así lo
está reseñando la agencia reuters
citando una alta fuente gubernamental en
1968 hasta los restaurantes más pequeños
que vendían perros calientes fueron
nacionalizados hoy en día son más de
siete mil pues el plan del gobierno
sería convertir la mayoría en
cooperativas y negocios privados y que
sólo unos pocos queden en manos del
estado una de las declaraciones que
confirmarían la noticia vino de parte
del ministro de economía alejandro hill
el mes pasado ante el parlamento el
funcionario dijo que la gastronomía
estatal debería mejorar su eficiencia y
los salarios y además que se tenía que
acabar el des
de recursos valentina daniela y de
cubanos vamos hasta eeuu porque millones
de desempleados están a punto de
quedarse sin ayudas si el empeoramiento
de la pandemia y el invierno están
acelerando los despidos en las empresas
y las ayudas federales se están acabando
solo en la última semana las solicitudes
de subsidios por desempleo subieron por
primera vez en cinco semanas hasta 742
mil este es un resultado mejor que en
marzo como vemos en el gráfico cuando se
dispararon a 6,8 millones pero sigue
siendo alto porque antes de la pandemia
lo normal eran 200.000 solicitudes
cuando alguien se queda sin trabajo en
eeuu recibe inicialmente un subsidio por
seis meses de 320 dólares en promedio
nacional pero hay un programa de
beneficios extendidos que dura 13
semanas más sin embargo tanto este
programa como otro también creado en
pandemia expiran el 26 de diciembre
cuando eso pase de los 20 millones de
ciudadanos que reciben algún tipo de
beneficios se estima que al menos la
mitad
voy a quedarse sin ayudas daniela y
ahora nos centramos en europa y le pido
que nos explique por que polonia y
hungría se están oponiendo al plan de
recuperación de la unión europea
mire valentina a los líderes del bloque
comunitario están discutiendo hoy un
plan de 1,8 billones de euros para
recuperarse de la recesión en los
próximos 7 años pero a pesar de que
todos los gobiernos están desesperados
por recibir ayudas y préstamos hungría y
polonia lo vetaron y sus razones son más
políticas que económicas ellos se oponen
porque el dinero está condicionado al
respeto del estado de derecho es decir
les será más difícil acceder a los
recursos quienes violen las normas
democráticas algo de lo que polonia y
hungría han sido acusados por décadas
pero eso qué significa que nos lo
expliquen la canciller alemana
esto significa que todavía no podemos
enviar la documentación al parlamento
europeo y que por lo tanto no puede
haber votación la próxima semana pero
también deje en claro que creo que el
compromiso que negociamos con el
parlamento europeo sobre el mecanismo
del estado derecho fue muy bueno y
equilibrados
daniela y la crisis del coronavirus
también tocó a las firmas de lujo sí
señora hay un informe de la consultora
bein and company que dice que este año
caerán en un 23% las ventas globales de
artículos de lujo hasta 258 mil millones
de dólares de todas maneras es mucho
dinero será la primera caída en 10 años
y la mayor desde que se recogen estos
datos agrega el informe que sólo ve a
una recuperación en 2022 o 2023 en el
mejor de los casos este sector se ha
visto sacudido este año también por la
pelea de gigantes entre tiffany's y
louis vuitton daniela y por favor
cuéntenos los indicadores de la jornada
wall street del cerro en terreno
positivo impulsado por las tecnológicas
y a pesar de los malos datos de empleo
en europa las bolsas bajaron lastradas
por el aumento de contagios en la región
y en latinoamérica resultados dispares
con méxico y argentina a la baja y por
ultimo daniela le pidió la cifra del día
de hoy se celebra en francia el bollo le
nouveau que es cuando salen a la venta
las botellas de vino de la cosecha de la
región que lleva el mismo nombre y que
está ubicada al norte de lyon y se llama
en un pop porque es un vino joven a
propósito de ese día de eurostat reveló
la lista de los principales productores
de vinos europeos italia españa y
francia son los que llevan la delantera
y la sigue en portugal alemania y
hungría todos producen en total 16 mil
millones de botellas por año valentino
daniela pues muchas gracias por toda
esta información por acompañarnos y a
ustedes también continúen con nosotros
estos france24
[Música]